[Music]
hello I'm - welcome to dear Hank and
John Norris I first think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give us
advice and bring you all of the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John how are you doing Bobby
wonderful you know what I did over the
weekend Hank no I built a tree house I
did hear that you were building a tree
house because at one point I called you
on the phone and you said I am building
a tree house right now yeah I built a
tree house with my but actually my buddy
Alex built the treehouse but I did a lot
of sawing and a fair amount of drilling
and probably a little bit of measuring
oh wow my assumption is that you may
have moved a lot of wood around I moved
a lot of wood around and then I drilled
a lot of wood into place but it was
amazing because I have a tremendous fear
of heights but I was reminded of that
line I first heard from Raj Punjabi of
last mile health that no condition is
permanent and even though I have a
tremendous fear of heights it turns out
that I am slightly more scared of social
embarrassment and so working working
with my fear of social embarrassment I
was able oh man to do it to stand on top
of that treehouse
even when it didn't have decking I was
once in a situation and the Grand Canyon
where a our our tour guide was like you
should go out here and walk along this
this like six inch wide path that on one
side has this a cliff face and on the
other side has nothing and then at the
end of it you will find a lovely view
and you can go and sit and contemplate
your thoughts and I was I mean here's
the situation
I knew I there was like not a great
chance that I would die but like a much
higher than usual chance right and so
I'm walking out on this thing and I'm
like you know what this is making me
feel is that like there is in no way a
situation in which I should be doing
this right but and I'm not doing it
because I'm enjoying it I'm only do
because this man who I do not know asked
me to and I did not want to embarrass
myself in front of a stranger and so I
am walking a lot and then I sat down and
I did the thing that he said and I sat
there and I just the whole time I was
just like I have to go back on that path
again
they were like and now you will feel at
one with the universe and you were like
I only feel fear I think I feel I feel
that that path is the only thing in my
life I have forgotten about everything
else my friend Chris is incredibly good
at not giving in to social pressure so
recently we were on a camping trip and
we were all like it was the middle of
the night and we were all like we're
gonna hike down to that Lake Chris it's
gonna be so fun it's so dark and we're
gonna hike all the way down to the lake
and then we're gonna hike up and chris
is like no and that's like you've gotta
go man it's gonna be amazing it's gonna
be so beautiful and he was like no
absolutely not I'm gonna stay here by
the fire yeah where it's nice well the
thing is John the problem is that I have
had many experiences in which I was like
I am NOT going to do that because of who
I am and the fact that like I know me
and then finally somebody convinces me
and then I do it and I'm like you're
right this was great and so I was like
maybe this guy's right maybe I'm gonna
walk down this path and at the end I'll
be like oh this is beautiful and I'm all
alone in the universe and and what is
what is me anyway and and then discard
all of the the useless things in my life
and only have the things that are great
but mandala that was not what happened
ya know we all want to glimpse the
interconnectedness of all things but not
at the expense of standing on the edge
of a cliff now all right I made it back
though John I'm alive to tell the tale
yeah this time can I can't we move on to
questions from our listeners you don't
have a come on you can do you have one
job John I actually have several jobs
and I have news from AFC Wimbledon and
I've gone through the questions I just
don't have a poem do you have you have
one more job than I have also I wrote an
episode of the anthropocene reviewed
over the last four days and I built a
tree house so here is a question from
Maya
right there John and Hank every day at
school during lunch I go to the
cafeteria to get a plastic fork as an
excuse to see my crush my family likes
to wash and save plastic forks so adding
one to the collection every day means
that we have a lot of plastic forks at
home I have a lot of questions about
your question Maya what should we do
with these plastic forks this does not
seem to me to be the central question
about your question should I host a
party celebrating Hanks book an
absolutely remarkable thing available
for pre-order now and coming out
September 25th where people might use
Forks alternatively what should I do as
an excuse to see my crush instead of
getting a plastic fork every day you
finally got there Maya that is your
question
Hank if you don't mind could you do the
sign-off you're more of the singer says
Maya hey Maya whoo Maya ha Maya ha ha
that's pretty good that's a pretty
if you liked 2007 YouTube you will love
that name specific sign-off all right so
I have I mean there's really only one
thing to do with these Forks John but
before we get to that do we want to talk
about the situation in which there is a
fork vendor
oh no I figured there's a cafeteria
where there's plastic forks plastic
spoons plastic knives my question is why
does Maya get a plastic fork every day
when Maya could be getting a plastic
spoon or a plastic knife so that once
every three days Maya has a full set of
silverware because what you really want
to do Maya is get like eight or twelve
full sets of silverware that you will
eventually use as your family cutlery
when you marry your crush and it will be
such a cute story
there'll be that's that's very cute you
have to get them like silver plated so
they'll be more durable of course Hank
that goes without saying you spend
thousands of dollars to silver plate
your plastic I was gonna say silverware
but of course it isn't silverware until
after you cover your plastic forks and
silver so I here's what you do with the
forks Maya obviously you got it take
each individual fork and paint it in a
beautiful way as if each one is a flower
and then you
them in a ribbon and and you present
them as if they are a bouquet of flowers
to your crush and you say I've not
needed any one of these forks I just
wanted to have you in my life oh wow I'm
giving you the forks back do you wanna
do you want to hang out sometime oh it's
so sweet but then there's a pretty good
chance that the crush is gonna be like
yeah no yeah that's life man that's how
it works
that's that's that's that's what having
a crush is all about is about that part
when they say no Maya you got to take
the risk here you got to do it you got
to paint each of those Forks
individually turn them into a fork
bouquet and the fork bouquet to your
crush and say exactly what Hank just
said it's adorable and I like it and if
it doesn't work you have a great story
in the future so that oh yeah Oh next
fall in love you can tell your next
partner you won't believe how great I
was to the last person just in general I
think there's a lot to be said for doing
dumb things that may be uncomfortable in
the moment but will at least lead to a
story that you can tell them the future
yeah although I would I would put a
slight asterisk after that comment one
of the things I really loved about the
movie love Simon I don't know if you've
seen it yet Hank but it's really I
thought it was really good one of the
things I really loved about love Simon
is there's one of these moments where
you know the person does something big
to try to confront their crush or
whatever but instead it's just so cringy
and uncomfortable so it can definitely
go all all wrong and you've got to be
conscious that like you don't always
want to be John Cusack holding up the
boombox especially if you know how the
person feels about you and you're doing
this to try to like win their affection
but it doesn't sound like Maya knows
that it seems like Maya is in that that
true in-between space where the cat
could either be alive or dead right the
box is not yet been opened it doesn't
necessarily seem like Maya knows that
much about forc person that is the only
permission we've gotten about fork
person is
is that they have some authority over
forks oh I didn't even think that they
had authority over Forks I thought that
like Maya had a different lunch period
or something or that's a great question
Hank what what is going on that was my
first question and you thought that it
wasn't interesting I take it back what
is that why why it appears that Maya has
very intentionally not given us this
information well but Maya does say what
should I do is an excuse to see my crush
instead of getting a plastic fork every
day like here's here's an idea you could
eat at the cafeteria
[Music]
why is that work that's a great question
I mean that's gonna be one of the
questions for that we don't know the
answer to and that just kind of we have
we have to live inside the mystery of
you know like oh absolutely yeah I mean
you could like you could eventually
develop a neural network that's like a
thousand times more powerful into the
human brain and all it's gonna give you
as probabilities of of what thing may
have happened and it's gonna be split
between a thousand different maybes so
your point Hank is that we should take
the most powerful neural networks in the
world and have them stop playing go and
trying to figure out autonomous driving
which they don't seem to be doing a good
job of and or yet them entirely towards
figuring out why Maya thinks it is
necessary to get a fork from the
cafeteria in order to see her crush
every day I mean at the moment it feels
like we might be using those algorithms
for less good things now I don't totally
disagree with you
let's move on to the next question
though this question comes from Holland
who asks dear Hank and John my car has
naturally bright headlights which has
its perks except that people often
mistake my low lights for highlights I
know your car and I do not like it no
I'll just go I'm gonna come right out
and say that my main problem is how they
respond they'll wait till just before
they've driven past me and then blast
their own headlights the highest setting
there's only one setting there's only
one other setting it's the highest one
yes they're the flash flash you with
their brights what do I do they don't
exactly give me a
time to explain that my headlights are
in fact on low should I just ignore it
I'm afraid that someday it may catch me
off guard so that I accidentally swerve
or hurt somebody or myself any advice
would suffice I'm at a loss Holland
here's the thing Holland you're gonna
need to get a different car I mean can
you go into the shop and be like my
lights are too bright I think that
naturally bright headlights is a little
bit like saying I naturally sneeze like
this which right there's just no way for
me to deal with the fact that my
headlights are so much brighter than
everyone else's there has been a way to
deal with it it's such a nightmare to be
faced with extremely bright lights when
you are on a country road at night in it
on a in a two-lane road situation it is
blinding so I'm completely sympathetic
to the people who are flashing their
brights at you because what they are
trying to communicate is ow
I'm scared yeah I can't like turn your
brights off please turn your bright I
mean you should not wait until you've
just gotten upon them to do it I don't
know like I tend to do that from a fair
distance but maybe they I don't know I
don't know but it seems like maybe go
see people see your dealer and be like I
think my headlights are too bright have
you ever gotten this complaint before
because it seems like I'm getting this
complaint regularly as I Drive a lot on
not great roads which was also included
in Holland's question and I'd escaped it
alright the next question comes from
James your writes Dear John and Hank it
seems like a really crazy time in
American politics these days but it also
seems like corruption and scandals and
fear and questionable hairstyles have
been around for as long as people have
been forming societies really great
observation James and I would argue
maybe even before that so why does it
feel like it's especially significant
now I mean we're not at war with our
neighbors so I feel kind of like this
time pales in comparison to the Civil
War though I suppose that is a pretty
high bar to get over yeah I the case
that there was a long period of like 40
years where things were pretty chill no
I'm making that up
yes no from like Watergate to to the end
of Obama you know I mean was not pretty
chill no don't you remember being a kid
and having to hide under your desk
during drills for how you would respond
to a nuclear holocaust that was a big
deal
yes that was a big deal that was very
stressful the Cold War was weird and
super intense right up until 1990 it was
pretty I mean I don't look we're things
this weird no things are very weird
right now and I think there is a
legitimate cause for concern I genuinely
think that and I don't just mean in the
United States
I think if things are just weird in one
country then it's sort of dismissible
because you know a lot of times the
pendulum will swing back or whatever but
when things are simultaneously weird in
a lot of countries I mean we've had
decades now of kind of pull back from a
feeling of interconnectedness across the
globe so we don't we aren't functionally
less interconnected like we're just as
likely to give each other the flu but we
are feeling less connected and and our
laws when it comes to trade and other
things are expressing that less
connectedness and I feel like what's
happening in Europe and in the United
States and to an extent also in South
America is an expression of that broader
thing that is the source of concern for
me definitely but I also think it is
nothing like a civil war it is nothing
like World War 2 it is nothing like
World War 1 it's certainly nothing like
you know 1848 or the late 18th century
there this is a weird time and I don't
want to minimize it but it's not the
weirdest time even of the last hundred
years you know the last 50 years and
James I do like that you called
attention to the fact that people have
had weird haircuts Oh forever yeah and
and I don't know that we should like I
do not really think that it's a good
idea to focus on the physical appearance
of your political enemies in these
conversations I know that it's fun but
it does not seem to help no it does
seemed to help on any level like know it
seems very counterproductive on every
level like it makes people listen to us
but it also makes people feel less human
so it seems to not accomplish either of
the whatever I love politics thank we're
moving on alright we're moving on to
another question
and this question is from Andy who asks
dear Hank and John I overheard this
question in the cafe at work a few weeks
ago and I've been thinking about it ever
since so matter can neither be created
nor destroyed right and there are six
billion more people on the earth than
there were when Alexander Hamilton first
rat battled Thomas Jefferson right so
that means there's a lot less of
something what is it
this questions making me Raggedy Andy no
that's good that's a good name specific
sign-off what what was it John what was
all that stuff all that stuff was Adams
it was like sandwiches and ravioli yeah
and now it's humans now it's humans
right is this this uh there was a slide
research if somebody said like oh I used
to weigh 68 pounds but now I weigh 70
pounds but matter can't be created or
destroyed how could this have happened
so there is a very interesting graph
that I found it's called the cumulative
biosphere pools over Giga years of time
and it goes this goes back pretty much
to the beginning of the earth and also
stretches on for a like Oh about a
billion years after now which makes this
graph somewhat terrifying because at a
billion and a half years after now
nothing's left so I don't know exactly
how they sketched that out but that's
that's what they've that's what they've
calculated so according to this a
billion and a half years from now there
there is no more living mass but biomass
this is the sort of measure of how much
living stuff there is on the earth at
any given point and right now that split
roughly equally between
prokaryotes single-celled prokaryotes
single-celled eukaryotes and then
multi-celled animals like ants and us
and and that number is of like us is
actually when I say us I mean
multi-celled organisms it's pretty
steady at the moment though it is maybe
decreasing a little bit which is the
thing I don't know if we should be
concerned about that but it seems to
maybe be decreasing a little bit and the
yeah so it's all roughly the same we are
a you know not an insignificant portion
of the biomass of the earth at this
point but we are not a like like not not
a big piece of the pie like you can
measure us but it it it only becomes
really significant when you measure all
of the things that we also control which
is like all the corn plants and all the
cows and chickens and stuff well when
you measure us plus all of the animals
that are exist solely for our use plants
and animals yeah it becomes a really
significant portion not as significant
of course as bacteria but significant oh
yeah yeah we control a great deal of the
multicellular biosphere of Earth yeah
although let's be clear
bacteria control us so who's really in
charge it's all system John none of us
can exist without without the others we
need to understand our
interconnectedness which is why we have
to walk out on very scary paths to the
edge of the Grand Canyon to see I don't
know man how do how do we imagine
ourselves correctly as interconnected as
we are I don't I don't have any great
suggestions for you but I find helpful
is to remind myself constantly that half
of the cells inside of me are not mine
this next question comes from Colette
who writes Dear John and Hank speaking
of complicated organisms Hank like
humans and ants Colette's question is do
ants sleep if so do they just stop the
middle of some grass and sleep did they
have designated sleep
places do they have bedtimes seeking
answers Colette Hank I thought you might
be able to answer this question because
you of course are known to be the
world's biggest super fan of an ant
colonies YouTube channel check out ants
candidate you do background / dance
Canada ants do kind of sleep like a lot
of animals they don't sleep kind of in
the way that we do but insects do you
have like a psyche like basically a
pattern of cycling through resting
periods and like there it appears me
that they do only sleep for a very short
amount of time so like eight minutes
every 12 hours according to a 1983 study
so that's a lot could have changed among
ants though in the last 35 years you
know it's true we sleep a lot less now
than we used to so maybe answered
staying up later you think it's not a
Netflix they roll it on their phone yeah
just like going through aunt Twitter and
feeling at the same time energized and
horrified and small and useless but
unable to stop scrolling it's a hard
life for an ant yeah it's it's weird to
think about how you measure whether an
ant is asleep or not so what they did is
they basically measured how much their
antennae moved which they took as a
surrogate for how like active they were
in observing their environment but I
don't know like what if it's like rapid
antenna movement sleep right great point
Hank what if they're dreaming yeah and
then it's like sniffing in their dreams
I'm gonna confess that I have not read
the majority of Ant Man comics but if
one of Ant Man superpowers is not that
he only has to sleep eight minutes every
12 hours they're missing a huge
opportunity narrative Lee yeah yes it so
I in continuing to read this it also
turns out that they studied the brain
waves oh my god oh my god put a tiny
little MRI machine - - ants even have
brains they don't really they have like
enlarged nerve
at the the end of the spinal cord like
barely yeah right now there's an alien
species doing an advice podcast about
humans and one of them said do humans
even have brains really stop aliens stop
watching us stop listening stop paying
attention will you alien things we don't
need to be monitored by you
we have souls with according to our
books at least ya know we feel it on the
inside aliens we feel real and they're
like yeah no we get that you feel like
you feel real they're like oh yeah no
that's what that's what's so cute about
you guys that's why we like watching so
much this next question comes from Johan
I think dear Hank and John why John is
there still no paperback version of
turtles all the way down available Hanks
book is even pre orderable as paperback
so I cannot accept Oh books will always
come out as hardcover first you just
have to wait as an answer it
banks book should not be available Oh
pre-order rotating that that yeah I
don't think that that is a thing it sure
better not be because I make less money
per book if the patron packs yeah that's
the short reason Johan is that hardcover
books are more expensive and they mean
that the author makes more money and the
publisher makes more money but I think
in the case of it's really that the
author makes more money I think the
author makes kind of the plurality or
majority of their money in hardcover
usually that's not always the case it
depends on the book depends on the
author but the reason hardcover books
exist is because you know authors get
like two or three dollars a book instead
of a number of cents yeah yeah and
please email us to let me know where you
saw the availability of a paperback
pre-order for my book you may have just
seen a discounted edition but I don't
know I would be couldn't
turned about that yeah I'm sorry that it
takes a long time for paperbacks to come
out it is it is kind of an unfortunate
function of the way that publishing has
figured out to survive in the current
the current landscape and in a lot of
cases paperbacks are taking even longer
to come out than they used to but yeah
once they're out they're out forever so
that's the good news I don't know how
long you'll have to wait until there is
a paperback of turtles all the way down
I'm sorry that you don't but it's man
it's $11 yeah for a pay for a hardcover
it's very cheap yeah yeah it's available
right now for like $11 with free
shipping if you don't I mean hopefully
wherever you are there are libraries
maybe there aren't but but that is you
know there are there is always the
library yeah absolutely yeah which and
often now libraries even have electronic
copies of books so that you don't have
to wait if the book isn't in stock yeah
yeah and supporting libraries is also a
really effective way to support authors
because libraries buy a wide variety of
books they don't just buy the most
popular books so I would actually argue
that libraries are in a lot of cases
kind of better for the literary
ecosystem than anything else so if you
really want to support a broad diverse
literary ecosystem I always think that
your public library is a good way to do
that of course choosing carefully what
kind of books you buy and read also
helps but I'm a big believer in
libraries Hank this next question comes
from Tenley who writes dear John and
Hank whenever I talk to adults about
their past experiences they often say
the same thing I've made a lot of
mistakes but I don't regret any of them
at what point does this at what point
does one acquire this mindset I'm 26 and
I know I've made a lot of mistakes like
the time I threw away my roommates
hamster but I regret all of them at what
age can I expect to be totally content
about all my bad choices regretfully Ted
wait
this is such a great question Tenley
because every time I hear someone say
like I've made a lot of mistakes but I
don't regret any of them because they
all led to me being here where I am
today I always think like no not all of
them like you made tons of mistakes that
had nothing to do with you being where
you are today like I would I would
submit Tenley that like you would not be
a substantially different person if you
had not thrown away your roommates
hamster well is is the idea to say like
but I'm so glad that I'm here and
without all the things that would have
happened I wouldn't be this exact person
and this is the person that I'm glad
that I am that's what I've always
interpreted it to be which is so
ludicrous because you don't know how
much better things might be yeah yeah I
mean I guess I guess you don't want to
think about that though you don't what
you like that's kind of an unpleasant
thought to be clear I have it all the
time and I'm perfectly aware that I have
made mistakes and regret them I've never
thrown away a hamster though no me
neither but I do have a ton of regrets
and I were and they are genuine regrets
and if I could go back and do things
again I would and I would do them
differently that's another thing I hear
all the time
oh if I could go back and live my life
I'd do it all the same I'm like I would
definitely not I would change a bunch of
things oh man I would God if I could
live my life over again i wou I would I
would hold on to so much less bitterness
over things that it turned out didn't
matter well there's that but also like
when I was 14 and a new eighth grader
showed up at my school I would have been
like hey this is gonna sound weird but I
know that we're going to get married
that probably would be an example of a
bad choice to make no however maybe
being like I am going to buy some Google
stock kind of thing that I would do
differently if I had my whole life to
live over I would bet everything on the
Cubs winning the World Series like of
course
man I've actually have a pet theory that
Elon Musk does have his whole life to
live over and that's how he's gotten
where he's gotten where he's just like
really early on he was like yeah I guess
now's about the time to join PayPal
yeah but the list of people who appear
to have had their life to live over is
short and definitely includes the Elan
musk John I just had the thought is
there any connection between the name
Harry Styles and the phrase hair style I
don't think so
was was was it where his parents aware
of this thing that they were doing I I
mean the important thing to note is that
Harry Styles born name is Harry Styles
okay this is the fact that you know you
did not look that up yeah Harry Edward
Styles I even know his middle name
oh my well Hank I don't know if you know
this I don't know if you've read Turtles
all the way down but there's a lot there
are a lot of Easter eggs for members of
the One Direction fandom and my new
novel Turtles all the way down a real
expert so that I could pull up a lot of
these down in here yeah I mean do you
not know that much about Harry Styles I
feel like it's like a very human thing
to have ingested a lot of Harry Styles
related information I gotta say I don't
know a ton about one direction John yeah
member of One Direction is at least by
some members of the One Direction fan
community believed to be in love with
Harry Styles this is an Aussie one is it
it's it's not lamps cuz he's not in oh
God Oh panic okay we're gonna have to
shut everything down vain
Zayn is a member of One Direction I
don't know that we can I don't know that
we can continue the podcast without
pausing for a One Direction listening
party in which I give you a bunch of
background on the One Direction fan
community
okay let's actually you know what Hank
we've got to move on to a different
question because I'm getting upset did
we answer the question yes i think the
question
it was a question you posed and it's
been answered which is that Harry Styles
was born Harry Edward Styles not Harold
Harry I mean it must the his parents
must have known that they were naming
him hairstyles
they weren't naming him hairstyles they
were naming him Harry Styles but they
were aware of this upon I you know they
the One Direction fan community almost
definitely knows the answer this
question which makes it embarrassing
that I don't is Harry Styles upon how
good I smell Harry Styles wrong it turns
out oh my god yes they feel if they'd
spelled it like hirsute then yes it
would have been an obvious pun there is
this is just a list of oh my god it's
it's called puns about Harry Styles
tumblr.com anyway think that reminds me
that today's podcast is brought to you
by tumblr tumblr Oh dot dot dot five
guests it's also brought to you by fork
bouquets com fork bouquets com providing
Forks for your crushes and today's
vodkas also brought to you by regrets
regrets I think it is appropriate to
have some just some and finally today is
brought to you by historically bad
hairstyles not historically bad Harry
Styles but historically bad hairstyles
of which there have been a number
today's podcast is also sponsored by two
podcasts that Hank and I have been
working on first you might enjoy the
Anthropocene reviewed if you like dear
Hank and John I'd actually don't know
that that's true but I make a podcast
called the Anthropocene reviewed which I
reviewed different facets of the human
centered planet on a five-star scale
there are two episodes now a third
episode will be coming quite soon it'll
be about Hank my new episode is about
the plant species Kentucky bluegrass and
the practice of googling strangers
I do like the anthropocene reviewed very
much John it is a well-structured
fascinating podcast and it's a quick
listen as well which is always off a
nice when I'm doing some specific tasks
that's gonna take about 20 or 30 minutes
well thank you I should also say that
this next episode is going to be
incredibly sad so like your podcasts add
that you've found a new home in the
Anthropocene reviewed I'm ready this
podcast is also brought to you by my
podcast with my wife delete this in
which Katherine and I go through my
Twitter feed over the last week in an
attempt to sort of like read I jest and
understand the tremendous amount of
things that have happened in the last
week things happen very fast these days
but also to analyze the way in which we
interact with the social Internet and
whether or not that is healthy and it's
great to have Katherine there for that
as a person who is not super involved in
the social Internet and so can tell me
how much all of this is bad and I am
doing it wrong and we also have a
project for awesome message this one is
from William girding of Texas Williams
says willful ignorance has infested
today's political climate the quick
short games of ignoring the problem and
hoping it goes away or passing it on to
the next generation can no longer be an
option for us our generation must be
willing to actually make the future
better for our children without footing
the bill on to them no more band-aids
for bullet holes says William we do have
big problems and we do not have a great
history of solving them although I would
say that there have also been places
where we have solved big problems that
we face together so I I feel like yes in
a lot of ways we've kicked a lot of
problems down the road and I think
Williams point is well-taken but there
are also a lot of problems that we
solved in the last 50 years or at least
things that we've made much better about
human life yes I agree I mean I I think
especially if you take a long view like
we are tremendously good problem solvers
and that has allowed us to you know feed
our children and stuff which we've been
just very good at and and that is
ultimately what we're all going yeah but
I think
Williams point is that we are also
excellent procrastinators as a species
and we don't always take the long view
and we need to yeah all right one more
question before the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon John sounds good
this one comes from Danielle who's asks
dear Hank and John I have been given the
wonderful opportunity to travel to
Thailand to work on an elephant
reservation this is clearly an exciting
experience I have been gifted however it
has come to my attention that I will be
on a plane alone for 22 hours what do
you do with all of that terrible time
alone I usually read during long travels
however I don't believe I have the
attention span for 22 hours worth of
plane time what do you usually do during
your long hours of travel during book
and movie tours any dubious advice would
be appreciated dinah soir our Daniele
well I there's a Nietzsche quote where
he wrote if you stare at the abyss long
enough the abyss will stare back oh gosh
so I just try to get to that point on my
game flights well the good news Daniele
is that you'll probably be in the you
know you'll sit down in the chair and
think this is okay 22 hours later you
will not be a big fan of your chair know
also people will tell you to sleep which
is a great idea if you're the kind of
person who can sleep you know in a tiny
tiny chair surrounded by strangers in
the 43rd row of a steel cylinder
traveling 35,000 feet above the ground
like if that's your ideal sleeping
situation Daniele then yes by all means
sleep but if you're a normal person
you're gonna sleep for like two and a
half hours you're gonna be incredibly
cranky when you land in Thailand you're
gonna be saying I don't even care about
elephants but then you just gotta like
get an afternoon nap
let yourself adjust to your new reality
which is that your body does not know
what time it is lean into that
experience and enjoy your time there
because the other thing is that you got
22 hours coming home
whatever that happens so obviously there
will be movies on the plane there will
be podcasts on your phone I think that
you listen to at least some podcasts as
my guess there will be
oh is it a good idea to listen to 22
consecutive episodes of dear Hank and
John on a plane trip to Thailand because
it might situation I will often either
listen to a book I've already listened
to or listen to podcasts I've already
listened to so it's okay in my
completely harebrained State to just
Waffle back and forth between sleep and
awake and not really know because it's
very hard to not sleep but it's very
hard to sleep for very long right and so
I like to listen to some media that I've
already listened to or watch something
that I've already seen so I'm not like
getting caught up in the story too much
right I would almost try to listen to
something new I honestly Danielle when I
get on a plane I try to get on the plane
with a huge variety of potential
entertainments because I don't know what
future me is gonna feel like if future
me wants to watch a movie then I try to
have a movie loaded on my iPad or my
computer if future me wants to listen to
a podcast I try to have like both
familiar ones and new ones downloaded
you you can't over prepare for a twenty
to nine hour flight
yeah you've got a load load up all your
devices with various media and and that
it will be over and everything will be
fine and the elephants will welcome you
with open trunks and I also have to say
that planes are made out of aluminum not
steel just no great that's sounds safer
because otherwise the people be adding
John all the time and it would be a
correction on next episodes okay
well John great cylinders made of
aluminum flying 35,000 feet above the
sky if basically basically just a empty
doubt coke can
that is not an image that I'm have found
at all helpful I thought that has sent
me in the wrong direction I am flying in
a large coke can that is something I am
going to think about every time I get on
a plane for the rest of my life goodness
gracious what is the news from Mars in
the news from Mars this week there was a
so-so as you may know there Russia had
its elections recently and Vladimir
Putin
walked away with a very large percentage
of the vote as surprising that he won
but yeah he was you know no issues there
yeah turns out if if no one can run
against you oh he had several opponents
Hank he only won 72 percent of 117
percent of the vote and in the midst of
this they the Russian government put out
a documentary about Vladimir Putin and
Vladimir Putin in this documentary
discussed Russia's near-term plans for
sending missions and people to Mars in
which he was very optimistic about their
ability to get missions to Mars by 2019
which what yeah which is I mean I don't
know if he's done the math on that but
human missions to Mars by Twitter you
launched a mission today you could maybe
get humans to Mars by 2019 like maybe
he's going to maybe I don't know but
Jamie today's a day there was there was
scant information about this in the
documentary and it was in Russian so I
only have secondhand reports but what I
can tell you is that the space race was
good for getting America to the moon and
the space race was indeed inspired by
competition between the US and Russia to
show how great each country was and we
showed them that we were great and maybe
that that kind of you know non-military
competition is gore it would push
forward maybe some exploration but in
general it's not great because we intend
to deprioritize science when we do it
that way
ah you know one thing I did not think
when we started this podcast hey-ya is
that by the end of it you would be Pro
Cold War what I think it's great it's a
nice provocative interesting call and I
like it well I like honestly what you're
hearing me say right now is maybe we
shouldn't
go to Mars by 2027 we should slow down
and not do it this way oh okay all right
that's a way to not do it this way that
would be great and to prioritize we
should slow down and go to Mars in 2029
or later Yeah right well I just I think
that we should do it cooperatively and
not as a competition and that good
should be a thing that brings the world
together instead of being a fight but
yeah I mean I guess if Vladimir Putin
wants to take the writ like they don't
have a great track record of getting
missions to Mars without them being
destroyed so I would not personally sign
up for that for that mission to be clear
I also wouldn't sign up for a mission
that was being run by Elon Musk or the
US government because of how I would
probably vomit a lot for a lot of months
before we got there and also I was very
scared about walking on the edge of the
Grand Canyon I don't feel like I'd be
great at just being on the edge of the
perpetual abyss so yeah but it doesn't
doesn't seem like the safest strategy
for Vladimir Putin to be like hey look
we're gonna have to look cooler than
America so let's get this together and
and and and just slap a couple coke cans
together see if we can get people to to
Mars
well that is uh that that is an exciting
and interesting development I also
recall the President of the United
States saying that he wanted to get
people to Mars by the end of his first
term and that yes that seems to have
been a promise that has fallen by the
way so yes
he also our president this week said
that Hillary Clinton wouldn't send
people to Mars and I was just like I
mean like what what's happening well is
he is he going to send people to Mars
because except that that seems like okay
that's a bit that's a bit of a straw man
argument however let us turn our
attention hanck to America's favorite
third tier English soccer team AFC
Wimbledon now with only nine games
remaining in their league one campaign
nestled uncomfortable
we in 18th place we have to finish in
20th or above we played Rochdale
roachdale Rockdale Rockdale last on
Saturday they are near the bottom but
they're near the bottom partly because
they've had a very good cup run but
anyway they're near the bottom and we
tied them which is not a great result
but if you were at the game or watched
it as I did on my phone then it is a
great result because we should have lost
we have a really good performance from
our goalkeeper George long I thought he
did a really good job and also they hit
the post they're really kind of the
inside of the post once they were
definitely I mean we were away from home
but they were definitely kind of
carrying the day but a one it puts us
one point closer to safety at this point
wimbledon are on forty two points three
that's right three points clear of the
relegation zone I still think we
probably need three wins or two wins and
two draws at least to stay up in our
last six our last nine games so yeah I
mean we've we need some results is what
it comes down to
but right now wimbledon are safe if the
season ended today wouldn't that be nice
we would end safely and we would have
another season in Ligue 1 the last thing
I want to say about the news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank is that demolition has
begun on the site where the new plow
Lane Stadium will be built and they are
aiming to be have that stadium finished
and ready for soccer for the 2019 2020
season so that is incredibly exciting
and I will certainly keep everyone up to
date on that that will be the end of a
long long long part of Wimbledon's
history it will be a great coming home
and even hearing the fans saying we're
coming home we're coming home when I was
at the Oxford game was very moving so
it's really yeah things are things are
good ish but
also kind of terrifying we have a note
from this is a soccer related note from
evylyn or Evelyn who hisses dear Hank
and John hi my name is Evelyn and I'm
confused about this peterborough third
tier soccer team you speak of I'm sure I
play for a you 14 first to your soccer
team from Peterborough Ontario where
does your Peterborough team come from
and are they any good Ontario and
Toronto Ontario I say on tape on charity
are Ontario Evelyn I'm about to totally
blow your mind so I hope you're sitting
down a lot of place names in Canada are
named after place names in Great Britain
and you'll never guess why it's because
the Queen's on your money man you got
the Queen on your money
yeah I mean Evelyn you have queen
elizabeth ii on your money Peterborough
is also a town in the great nation of I
could never remember if it's England or
Great Britain I don't like to offend
those people and they're very
persnickety about which is which well
it's it's definitely in Great Britain
it's also with England Canada Evelyn the
important thing is that Canada is a
colony of England and that is why you
live in a town called Peterborough John
do you know where Peterborough got its
name yes I don't I've got a guess I've
got a guess I is it from the Apostle
Peter I don't I don't know John I was
just I just wondered if you knew the
answer the dumbest guy should I've ever
been asked in my entire life it replaces
the previous toughest question what
question did you hope I would ask that I
haven't asked oh gosh mmm-hmm
I was recently doing an interview and
the person I was interviewing asked me a
question and I was just like no
I can't answer questions right now I
have extremely focused on how nervous I
am to interview you oh okay we are we
are completely wrong on every level what
do you mean I mean that Peterborough is
not named after the town in England
that's just convergent name evolution
it's named after Peter Robinson an early
Canadian politician who oversaw the
first major immigration to the area so
there you go it also its nickname in the
distant past was the electric city as it
was the first town in Canada to use
electric streetlights
well let's bring it back like bring back
the electric streetlights yeah well no
just bring back start calling the
electric Artie again I think that sounds
alright I gotta find out who
Peterborough in England was named for
Hank like looking at the Wikipedia page
and it makes no sense I do not
understand stupid but I'm so annoyed now
and I gotta figure it out so what if you
do what did we learn do all four of the
what did we learned while I'm figuring
out this stupid Peterborough question
all right so what did we learn today
John well tink we learned that Harry
Styles is named harry edward styles and
may or may not have been a pun that
Harry Styles his parents were playing on
him we also learned that there are some
fork people and some fork people are
acute and we don't know why they have so
many Forks but also some people save
their plastic forks which is not
something that I do I throw them away
every time though I was at the frozen
yogurt place yesterday and the people
asked the people at the firs in yogurt
place if they washed the spoons to reuse
and they were like no and then they all
took their spoons with them which I
guess so there you're not the only one
Maya we also learned that
John and I have regrets and that's
normal but we never threw away anybody's
hamster and finally John we learned that
Peterborough is not named after
Peterborough I did it
I still have an answer your stupid
question and it's gonna drive me crazy
it's weird it's not weird makes no sense
god it's stupid superin I'm gonna have
to let go first I'm gonna have to figure
it out second I'm gonna have to edit
this Wikipedia page to make sense god
I'm so annoyed
who's the Peter who's Peter God it's a
very simple question about the burro
I don't care where it's located I don't
care when it was founded who the F is
the Peter if the love of God all right
Hank let's just take five minutes all
right this is stupid and annoying but
let's just both of us take five minutes
to figure out what Peter peterborough is
named for and then we'll hard cut to us
when we know all right I'll talk to you
in five minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah yes okay what'd you get in honor of
the saint - who it was dedicated this is
from a Google books result in 970
however some Bishop of Winchester
restored it by the assistance of Edgar
and his Queen and from meda Hampstead
its name was changed to Gildan burg
golden city for its riches and again
from that to Peterborough in honor of
the saint to whom it was dedicated so
there we go at last that better be the
answer I'm not digging any deeper it's
in a book John it's gotta be real it's
not even a website yeah it is and the
book is called a geographical dictionary
of England and Wales so it seems like it
should be reliable oh god it's over oh
thank you sir not to be turned out of
that book it turned out to be the person
I was guessing from the very beginning
but I'm just glad that it's over I've
been able to close the loop and now we
can read the credits this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson are kind of community and
communications Victoria ba was a very
weird noise what my giggle yeah it just
cuz it came in like our head of
community you were like laughing about
you being all weird about Peterborough I
wasn't weird about it I just needed to
answer the question before we could move
on the music that you're hearing right
now and beginning the podcast and during
this week at Ryan's which is available
to our patreon patrons whose give over 5
dollars a month it's a dumb podcast
where we try to stuff each other about
people not named Ryan and you can get it
and love it and I love all you who love
it is available at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John you could send us
questions it is Hank and John at
gmail.com and it's also you can do that
on Twitter I'm Hank green John and John
John is John Green and as they say in
our way oh wait wait two things first
off I don't think you ever said the name
of our head of community and
communications was which is Victoria
Bonjour no and also I don't think you
ever said
the music that we were listening to that
were presumably still listening to is
gonna roll our nope never said you never
said gunnarolla impossible you're right
I didn't get to that part
thanks for listening and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]